like that's dad
[Music]
insane insane
[Applause]
over the last year year and a half I've
made a lot of promises about the number
of videos that I was going to make the
consistency with which I would be
uploading new content and all of those
promises have turned out to be empty but
I love this format I remained committed
to finding a way to doing this in a more
facile way that would work within that
construct of my busy life and all the
other things that I'm working on so a
couple months ago I put the word out on
my podcast in search of a filmmaker and
editor who could be my partner in crime
so that I could step into this YouTube
platform in a meaningful way I have
concluded the search I think I found a
guy David come over here pull the chair
up over here
David is a super talented filmmaker
cinematographer photographer and editor
so David travelled all the way from
multiple actually technically Bali is
way over last a women of prayer because
he wanted to explore this opportunity
you're starting to get a feel for each
other and how we might work together and
I'm really excited so tell me why you
responded to my my shout out to my my
call yeah well I've been a big fan on
the show for a while but when I heard
that you you were looking for someone it
just it just was a no brainer for me you
know I instantly compelled to just reach
up and I just threw everything that I
had trying to make this happen and
[Music]
here we are going downtown to a
restaurant called the Springs to have a
celebratory dinner with friends friends
of the podcast friends personally to
celebrate what has been an incredible
year celebrating tonight actually it's
really fun time for us to celebrate
everybody who's been supportive of us
whose house does who's been with us
along the journey we're just taking a
pause to enjoy some of my amazing plant
base
and also from his chances nut so anyway
it's a really special night rich and I
are super excited for your film Eric
and much love to our partner Greg and
for putting all this on
[Music]
incredible extraordinary I can't believe
it was five years since finding Ultra
first came out it's been ten years since
Julie and I kind of began the first
steps of this journey and just looking
back over the last year it's kind of
amazing what we've been able to
cultivate and create and express and it
doesn't happen in isolation I don't do
any of these things alone Julie doesn't
do what she doesn't like it only happens
with the love and support of a lot of
people and a lot of those people are you
guys in this room tonight
[Music]
I mean your most authentic dreams and
expressions you all that was superb
awesome it's so nice to just see so many
people I love all in one place together
just eating great food and you know
celebrating this crazy journey that
we've been honest about us you see how
there's people out there
[Music]
and now please welcome to the stage from
Santa Monica
to the right to free our minds but not
to be out minds to step outside of
ourselves so we can see our minds see I
refuse to be afraid of my fears humanity
would only need to look to nature to
conform it destroys and it creates but
it doesn't take more than it needs it
doesn't bleed more than it feeds it
fights for life and then it need at
first it's nothing
the nothing turns into a whisper turn
the dial and it gets crisper and your
transistor wait a while and the whisper
turns into a screen it overwhelms your
system that you don't know what it means
but pump the bottom up and tell you all
your dreams to pretty soon is the only
words you'll ever need now you have to
do is listen when you want to leave your
fear disintegrates when you decide to
stop and breathe is your authentic voice
and no matter where you go in life will
never leave and that's God
[Applause]
and cool to be able to celebrate with my
friends and then give them that gift
that they can then take home
[Music]
you